con nuestro segundo invitado del día
vamos a hablar de las migraciones que
junto a todas las crisis actuales se
incrementan y generan nuevos flujos
migratorios son varios los factores
crisis climática conflictos armados y
también falta oportunidad sobre todo en
los países del sur y Centroamérica y
también África saludamos a joseppe él es
el jefe de la misión de la organización
internacional de las migraciones en
Panamá giuseppe gracias por su tiempo
por estar con nosotros en directo
América de France 24 y le pregunto de la
situación de la migración en el mundo
digamos en rasgos generales para poder
luego ir desglosando este tema qué datos
nos puede entregar aumentado realmente
la migración
Buen día Sí claro Hay muchas crisis
ahora y
y dices que tienen un impacto directo
sobre la migración en muchos países en
muchas regiones
Ucrania y Rusia por supuesto ocho
millones de personas desplazadas
internamente y cinco de más millón de
personas que ya dejaron el país los
venezolanos aquí cerca de nosotros en
Panamá y Colombia y en toda la región
más de siete millones de personas que
dejaron Venezuela y según los datos
oficiales y y mucho más crisis que tal
vez son olvidadas también como yemen y
otra todo tienen el mismo lo mismo Bueno
un impacto fuerte sobre la movilidad de
las personas y aquí en Panamá yo lo veo
diariamente con todos los flujos que
están llegando de todos esos países 7
más nacionalidades están cruzando la
selva del darián ahora de todos esos
países de Asia de África de
latinoamérica y este año fue una un año
récord claro giuseppe nos venimos
precisamente a nuestra región de América
Latina y el Caribe para hablar de esa
crisis migratoria que digamos todo este
flujo pasa por todo Centroamérica para
llegar al norte México digamos que
serviría como el gran tapón o para
llegar al final que es Estados Unidos en
la mayoría de los casos y y Canadá
también no Pero entonces cómo están las
condiciones sobre todo en nuestra región
de América Latina y Centroamérica que
obligan a a millones de buscar una una
mejor vida y si esto podría empeorar el
año que viene cuál puede ser las
predicciones A lo mejor que podemos
hacer de frente a este 2022 con el 2023
Sí claro bueno no se sabe claramente que
por el año próximo pero este año 2022
fue un año récord con muchísimas
personas que
están cruzando y cambiaron las
direcciones también porque
a veces con medidas que se tomaron por
ejemplo en los Estados Unidos muchos
venezolanos regresaron hacia Panamá y
esa es una situación totalmente nueva
para el país y yo diría para la para la
región también
hay hay migrantes que están que no saben
qué hacer exactamente por todo por la
situación que es muy difícil en el
darián pero no solamente y se quedan un
poco más tiempo en Panamá o en otro país
también que están considerando que hacer
en este momento Entonces
pero los retos van a continuar y los
desafíos económicos en Todos esos países
violencia cambio climático también es un
tema entonces creo que vamos a ver una
una continuidad en este movimiento pero
no sabemos exactamente Cuántos Y si la
dirección sigue siendo la misma del sur
hacia al norte las rutas son muy
complejas y vienen de Lejos de como
decía antes de Asia de África hacia
Brasil Chile Colombia y continúan hasta
eh Hasta México justamente para buscar
una mejor vida y mejores condiciones
para ustedes y para sus familias y tal
vez viajan juntos con con toda la
familia y tal vez la familia La familia
se queda en el país de origen y es la
razón principal para los migrantes para
para irse
vamos a hablar de ese fenómeno
migratorio por consecuencia de la crisis
climática que estamos viviendo
actualmente en el mundo pero hablabas de
de retos mayores que enfrenta también en
la región para poder soportar todo este
flujo migratorio Cuáles son esos retos
principales que los gobiernos y también
organizaciones deben tener en cuenta no
para que esto no se siga convirtiendo en
un problema mayor
Bueno sí lo necesitamos más información
es por ejemplo dados
necesitamos de más cooperación entre los
países ningún país el país puede
enfrentar esta crisis es solo se
necesita cooperación regional compartir
informaciones compartir políticas
también porque
por ese por ejemplo en Panamá Costa Rica
Colombia también están enfrentando la la
mayoría de estos cambios Porque cambian
los flujos cambia la nacionalidades
cambia las direcciones de los flujos
Entonces si no hay políticas
común
cada país no puede hacer mucho solo y
hay retos de humanitarios también para
todos los países que se que todos los
personas que se quedan en un país
extranjero para un tiempo bastante largo
tal vez y que busca que necesitan de
todo atención de salud alimentos no
tienen lugar donde donde están no hay la
capacidad por ejemplo en Panamá de los
albergues siempre está al límite máximo
de su límite máximo entonces esos son
retos diarios
pero tenemos que buscar soluciones a
mediano y largo plazo porque
este los flujos están continuando y van
a continuar claro también toquemos otro
punto importante del que estábamos
adelantando hace hace un ratico la
migración por factores climáticos o no
que por lo que vemos y las proyecciones
se que hacen los organismos
internacionales en torno al clima se
podían pronunciar se podían aumentar si
no atajamos la crisis climática como se
debe y si no tomamos ya cartas en el
asunto que nos puede decir sobre estas
personas que cada día migran no por
razones de seguridad o por Buscar
digamos otras cosas sino por el clima
que los obliga a salir de sus zonas de
vivienda
son migraciones forzadas también
y el tema está es un tema económico
también personas que familias que están
perdiendo su
su economía local y su cultivaciones por
ejemplo en muchos partes del mundo no es
solamente en esta región pero los
impactos lo vemos aquí también en la
región solamente hay amenazas
ambientales también el año 2021 Cuba y
Titi Brasil Estados Unidos también todos
países que sufrieron de de este de
cambio climático y de impacto de de
huracanes y otro y otros fenómeno
Entonces es un tema muy actual por
supuesto hay aumentan la persona que se
están que están en movilidad por causa
del cambio climático y también hay una
a un impacto sobre el ambiente desde
estos flujos masivos porque ahí hay otro
tema y lo vemos muy bien en el dariana
ahora
plásticos
gestión de basura y todo eso es no los
países aún no están listo para gestionar
y manejar este las consecuencias de del
flujo migratorio en tema
climático y de medio ambiente también